تقصف روسيا أوكرانيا
بالصواريخ مع استمرار الحرب لما يقرب من
عامين بعد غزو واسع النطاق.
قال الرئيس الأوكراني فادير زالينسكي إن
روسيا أطلقت ما لا يقل عن 500 صاروخ
وطائرة بدون طيار على الأراضي الأوكرانية في
الأيام الخمسة الماضية بما في ذلك
قصف هائل على كييف وهار.  يوم الثلاثاء،
ينضم إليّ سي إل إيه سيباستيان من سي إن إن على الهواء مباشرة من
لندن، صباح الخير لك يا كلير، فما
هو آخر
هجوم روسي لا هوادة فيه على أوكرانيا،
نعم روزماري، هذا هو حقًا نوع
السمة المميزة الآن لما نراه يحدث مع
مرور العام  أوكرانيا
سنة جديدة قاتمة للغاية حيث حدث
تصعيد كبير أه في
الحرب الجوية التي تشنها روسيا الآن نعلم
أن عدد المصابين من
هجمات الثلاثاء هو 130 شخصًا وعدد القتلى
5 مجرد مقياس لمدى كآبة
هذا الجديد  لقد مر عام على الرغم من أن مفتاح
الإدارة العسكرية للمدينة
قال للتو إن شخصًا آخر توفي في
المستشفى نتيجة الإصابة التي أصيب بها
في 29 ديسمبر/كانون الأول، والتي تقول أوكرانيا إنها كانت
أكبر قصف جوي
لمدنها منذ بداية الحرب، لذا فإن
تداعيات  مستمر في هذه الأثناء،
وكان هذا في الواقع تبادلًا
للهجمات الجوية، كما اتهمت
روسيا أوكرانيا بمواصلة هجومها الجوي
عبر الحدود في منطقة بلجيكا،
وبعض عشرات الصواريخ أه، وتقول روسيا إنها
أسقطت هذا الصباح بعد
عدد من الهجمات يوم الثلاثاء حيث
قال حاكم بلغار إن شخصًا واحدًا
قُتل بشظايا وأصيب 11 آخرين،
ثلاثة منهم ما زالوا في المستشفى لذلك
تشعر تلك المنطقة أه بالضغط
أيضًا رغم أن أوكرانيا لم تعلن
مسؤوليتها عن ذلك لكن أوكرانيا
توضح أيضًا أنها كذلك  ليست
عاجزة أمام هذه الاعتداءات الروسية
رغم أه التردد
الذي نراه في الكونجرس بشأن المزيد من المساعدات
تمكنت من إسقاط غالبية
الصواريخ التي أطلقت عليها يوم
الثلاثاء منها 10 من 10 تقول
كنجال أه هذه صواريخ  التي
تطلق عليها روسيا اسم Hypersonic، وهي من
أكثر العناصر التي يتم التباهي بها في
الترسانة الروسية وأعتقد أن مقياسًا لذلك هو
أن الجنرال زوزي، قائد
القوات المسلحة، خرج وتحدث إلى CNN بالضبط
حول هذا العنصر من هذا، ألقِ
نظرة اليوم  لقد أسقطت القوات الجوية الأوكرانية
10 من أصل 10 صواريخ دفاع جوي روسية من طراز x47 M2 kinal
باستخدام
صواريخ باتريوت أرض جو، وهذا رقم قياسي
لو وصلت هذه الصواريخ إلى
أهدافها لكانت العواقب
كارثية. أشكر جنودنا على
عملهم وأنا  نشكر شركائنا على
أنظمة الدفاع الجوي الخاصة بهم، لا يوجد
سبب للاعتقاد بأن العدو
سيتوقف هنا ولهذا السبب نحتاج إلى المزيد من
الأنظمة والذخيرة
لهم، لا يوجد سبب للاعتقاد بأن العدو
سيتوقف هنا، فهو يفعل شيئين هناك
أعتقد أنه مثير للاهتمام  الفضل
للوطنيين في محاولتي أعتقد الرد على بعض
الانتقادات التي رأيناها
بالتأكيد في الكونجرس حول أين
تذهب الأموال وكيف يتم استخدامها،
وثانيًا، أعتقد أن استخدام هذه الهجمات لإظهار
العالم حقًا
وخاصة حلفاء أوكرانيا
كم هو مطلوب من الجيش روزماري